[Musique]
messieurs du slave oui mes chers amis
auxquels mandat mais avant de fermer ses
dix neuf c'est ce soir qu'a lieu le
grand bal de la mairie je veux pouvoir
l'être ma jolie robe bleue écoute et
justement je lisais mon carton
d'invitation je pense bêtement ce manque
est mort à mouthe enfin je serai
l'événement de la soirée bien sûr dites
moi elle ce propos il ya quelque chose
qui me tracasse bon je crois que
françois n'a pas de costume que
pourrions-nous faible et ne bougez pas
je vais lui en parler tout sultan
mon cher françois bonjour aux messieurs
les snobs vous tombez bien je suis très
ennuyé monsieur du snch je n'ai rien à
billets pour aller ce soir au bal de la
mairie et c'est écrit en toutes lettres
tenue de gala exigé mais mon cher ami
c'est l'occasion ou jamais pour vous de
louer un habit
moi moi un avis vous croyez mais c'est
ce que je vais mettre ce soir moi je
connais un très bon loueur dhabi c'est
une bonne idée pourquoi pas et je vous
assure qu'après moi vous serez le plus
beau de la soirée après vous
je suis invitée au grand bal de la
mairie à la fois que tu mettes un habite
aussi non pas du tout casimir autant que
casimir us peut aller comme bon lui
semble bravo françois simon sous l'eau
mais retiens ma présence il n'acceptera
tel que je suis c'était un bon je
m'appelle tout de suite mon look date du
6 janvier
allô allô allô allô allô oui ce chiffre
bonjour monsieur du snob je vais jouer
bien joué et merci pour un an voilà avez
vous un costume pour france 3 oui
françois oui très bien formidable à
écouter c'est très simple je vous envoie
casimir va vous apporter ces mesures
entendu je vous remercie beaucoup au
revoir monsieur chiffre parfait c'est
parfait tu fais été mesure françois mézy
eh bien je vais les prendre vivants de
l'usiné ces miraculés note oui
qu'est ce que je ferais
jamais réussi à changer l'année incarnez
du canal à bord
70-70 la carrure 70 à 6 56 le bras son
fils war 3 voilà le tour de cou 3 57 37
66 70 77 ans voilà attention au coût de
5 à la jambe jean macé 68 ça fait râler
mesure jaro 40 le prix veut débusquer
car encadrer la tête quand l'assaillant
à brega mais bien je me couchais
monsieur foé demain c'est pas trop 27
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous êtes prête moins cher ami peintre
est monsieur 10,9 au
alors il a les mots me manquent pour
exprimer mon admiration chez rami a et
moi comment me trouvez
vous êtes luisant
luisant ma chère à mais vous pouvez
toujours le mot qu'il faut et qui fait
plaisir
dites moi vous allez lui françois non
pas encore j'espère que votre amie laura
trouver un costume à sa taille ne vous
inquiétez pas cher ami monsieur chiffon
ou bien qu'étant un homme très distrait
à des costes une toutes les tailles
alors vous voyez je pense qu'il ne va
pas tarder je leur ai donné à casimir et
à lui et rendez vous ici oui bon moteur
tu es magnifique attitré
manificat j'ai été chercher la vitre en
soit il aurait en fils il sera là une
minute à l'autre à c'est parfait
déjà alors qu'on a beau tout va bien je
ne savais pas qu'elle a dit se porter
aussi 20 cette année
matières plus croquant qu'une pique
nique fait chier la [ __ ] lui même n'est
ce pas quasiment alors je ne vois qu'une
explication est devenu complètement fou
à moi je vois mon nom je vais donner en
même temps ni musulman pour me fabriquer
un petit costume de marin mais mais
c'est ça mais il les a confondus avec
les mines aussi la race ne se chiffrent
de plus en plus distraits et goûter il
faut faire quelque chose il suffit de
faire quelques petits contrats oui
peut-être autour de moi et que je peux
faire
ça mais
voilà on sait qu'il est nécessaire mais
j'ai aussi mal à contrôler après que le
rabaisser un peu plus la cote à la la la
la haute saône en charge et pour
terminer tout petit rôle gauche ici
également la voix l'attention
écoutez que casimir monsieur dit stop
julie ne nous écoute je vous en prie je
vous aurais ça suffit comme ça vous êtes
bien amusés tout le monde a ri bon allez
à la mairie dans cette tenue jamais en
chemise à carreaux ça l'aidera milieu
auquel demain chinois wahaha
[Musique]